Hello, welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips!
This month, we're looking at leadership versus management.
What does this mean?
An expert in this field is a gentleman called John Kotter...
...who's a professor of leadership at Harvard Business School.
He argues that management is focused very much on complexity,...
...dealing with the complex daily routines such as budgeting, organizing, problem solving, etc.
All very important, but not leadership.
John Kotter says leadership is to deal with change,...
...helping companies grow, develop, and move into new areas.
He identifies four principles to being a successful leader.
First, create vision and strategy.
A leader has a clear vision of where they want to go to and their company to go to,...
...and strategy sets the map how to get there.
Second, communicate and set direction.
A good leader needs to be a good communicator.
They need to communicate their vision clearly to the people they work with...
...and also set a clear direction for everybody to move forward.
Third, motivate action.
Here, emotion is key.
A good leader should be using persuasive skills,...
...inspiring, praising, recognizing the work of others,...
...to encourage them and motivate them to successful action.
Finally, align people.
A good leader needs to make sure everybody is working in the same direction.
Everybody is aiming at the same goals.
This is key to success of achieving the vision.
Now remember, anybody can be a leader.
It doesn't have to be a manager to be a leader.
So, use these four principles to become a leader yourself.
Thank you and good luck!